and we're off
let's do it
nico nasty jester go go eric
luffy man vadant malik what is up
everybody we are
here the finale of loki
it's kind of sad isn't it it's very sad
what is uh mr anderson
the best mod is here all right
who's ready who is
ready what is going
on everybody all right so i'm already
i'm already seeing some people
talk about i'm already seeing kang gang
i'm seeing dr
doom thrown out there everybody comment
down below who you think it is right now
just
just
go just go kang superior loki king loki
whoever
whoever you think it's going to be
whatever you know dr
doom wanda i heard that theory thrown
out there today because
because time isn't linear right which
makes sense so let's just let's just
hear
let's just hear who it is i see kang
gang uh show my socks i'm not wearing
socks right now i'm
in my home i'm comfortable i'm
comfortable
all right whatev you know audio seems
good
cool all right
oh miss minutes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah miss minutes miss minutes
kang dr doom for life but do you think
it would be
good timing to to to put him in right
now
i feel like that would be rushed let me
uh let's fix this cam there we go
sweet sweet kang miss minutes
kang so wanda thor
how funny would that be freaking thor
the whole entire time
just playing a a big freaking joke on
his brother
some people were even saying classic
loki um
could be it that his death was actually
just an illusion right
why isn't there we go which i think
would be
would be insane so i i personally don't
care the only thing i really care about
is mobius riding away in a jet ski in
the end
like yeah i
if we don't get that it's going to be so
such a waste hey infinity shades hey
again maybe been watching every stream
since one of his start it's been a
pleasure we hope lucky becomes worthy of
this episode hey thank you so much i
know you have
and you're always coming to clutch those
super chats i super appreciate that
and uh yeah we have a little bit of
break between
uh this tonight
and uh what if august 11th i believe
but we'll be back oh i see some odin
is the main villain couple of people
throwing some deadpool and krog yeah
that was
that was freaking awesome so i think we
all know it's mephisto right
no just kidding just kidding just
kidding just kidding uh let me
how was hey trevor radley how's the heat
uh
you know i'm feeling really hot right
now i am wearing a jacket and i did just
play a hockey game
but uh yeah it's it's it's been up there
man it's been over a hundred it's
it's been pretty crazy hey gary phillips
thanks for super chat
hey but i've watched your videos for a
while love your stuff god bless hey god
bless back to you gary
uh super appreciate that i hope you've
enjoyed them um
hope you continue to enjoy them uh rada
thank you for that super chat we need a
wow
from mobius yeah i totally agree i was
it the director that said we don't get
it though
was that i think that's who said right i
think
the director said we we weren't going to
get it
but we you know we all
we all know what that really means uh
today i interviewed taskmaster and i
won't say any spoilers for the movie
but i asked i'll just say task master if
they i will say will be returning
for anything else in the future
and of course the i got the diplomatic
answer asked the studio but then of
course
they went on to say i would love to
return
i think some people asking me about the
loki sylvia betrayal
i'm gonna be really disappointed
if that happens like genuinely i'm gonna
be really disappointed i feel like
that's expected
and i feel like i want the unexpected
and i think the unexpected
is for loki to fall in love with himself
with an
actual other person not necessarily
himself right but like with an
actual other person and i just feel like
i just feel like it would be a waste i i
don't know
stripe thanks for supporting luke is
really messing up my sleep schedule yeah
you're telling me
uh i'm actually i'm actually saying um
freaking disney's messing up my freaking
sleep schedule like like you know
what uh warner brothers hbo max
when they started releasing things you
know like wonder woman 1984 came out at
like what
10 in the morning or something like that
like why don't you do that
isaiah richardson jr coming in with
another super chat oh he's coming in
clutch oh no i'm where does it say i
missed it i'm going to die if miss
mennon is behind the tva
well i think what
miss minute said was true i think she is
kind of alive kind of an ai
um i think so i think that kind of a
light
alive part might actually care about who
created her
and is working for who created her of
course but i you know
i don't think she's the main villain but
that'd be so funny right
ishmael montoya coming in with uh
another super chat as well
every week your plot the villain is a
variant loki
but the variant is killed by kang at the
end to introduce himself to him to you
wow how crazy would that be right
i i do think
we get a kang post credit scene i just
think there have been
there's just been two
there's been too much pointing towards
king for him not to be
mentioned right i mean
yeah hey bradley jones thanks for coming
in for the super chat
uh yeah i'm gonna miss them too i'm not
gonna lie i i do miss them but i will
continue to do them
at a normal time uh until we get
until we get what if and we'll be back
here doing it again oh crap
i missed one clinton thanks for super
chat final prediction
look at varian that is working for kang
they'll tease and post credit love the
streams
keep it up thanks so much man um
or woman sorry um i love doing them i
love
having everybody in here and
i have to agree with your prediction i
think it's gonna be
i sadly think it's loki in the castle
but i i think kang is behind everything
or what i said in my video today i
actually think it could be a variant
of kang like a mortis who's like kind of
good
and then like the real kang shows up in
ant-man three
nash senadiki it's unlikely king shows
up before three yeah
um i guess i kind of just stated my
opinion on that about
uh a variant of kang right i think a
variant of king
might show up but not like the real king
so
we'll see uh i'm i'm i'm hoping for
something
extremely unexpected
i i really hope so gorov
aurora your videos have helped me
through some depression so thank you man
i made a bet that king would be post
credit saying hey i'm so glad i could
help
um really i and i know what that's like
to to be down in that in that hole so
i'm glad i could help thank you for that
comment it helps me um and
yeah i think kang's post credit post
credit scenes right uh c
jenkins no way home trailer release
after this we can hope right i mean yeah
from what i understand with what this
what's gonna happen tonight i
i think they had to wait until after
loki i think we're gonna see the
multiverse tonight
um i really do thanks for that super
chat
uh did i miss one
try not to miss any super chats
infinity shades my cousin's best friend
is mates with chris hemsworth really
so you'll most likely be able to make
thor they nice try to get chris quite a
stream like
hey that would be super cool yeah
totally that would be really cool if you
got to meet him
he seems just like a really
uh awesome dude isaiah beltran
pertaining to kang
has ever been a time where a villain
announced for a future movie appeared
earlier than expected um
well i think with the infinity saga it
was all new
so no it wouldn't be oh i get what
you're saying though you're talking
about like
they announced kang frank man three and
then he came uh no but i wouldn't put it
past
marvel in the slightest that could that
could be that could be a tactic by
marvel right like oh we're going to
announce them for
for ant-man 3 but no one's going to you
know secretly we're going to
put him out for uh
loki and that's why that's why i think
sadly that it's not kang and the castle
because i have to i would have to agree
with the people
that are stating that it's it's for a
final you know
for a finale the ending of the saw i
feel like it would be
kind of rushed to just throw in kang
because keep in mind the general public
isn't like us
they're not up at for me one in the
morning for some people
two three in the morning you know and
and all around the world different times
you know some of these people are
watching live streams
and stuff like that and i think
i think it might be a
a little much might be a little much but
uh
a guy can hope when i first started when
you take into
consideration all of these different
things like qeng
the company that nathaniel richards or a
different alter ego of him
owned like nathaniel just is king that's
king's company we saw
an easter egg for that ravana ren slayer
is kang's lover the time keepers talk to
immortus which is another variant of
kang which i think
might show up at the end right it's just
kind of like
there's so much how how could he not be
involved at least
a little bit uh mr lights please thank
you for that super chat
i appreciate that so i just
you know i it'd be so crazy if kang's
not involved
in any way shape or form i just really
think that would be insane
doodle thanks for the super chat the
show has truly been something special i
can't wait to see how it ends tonight
i have been a fan of channels since 2008
by the way hey thank you you're no g i
think that's when i started my channel
so from the beginning appreciate that
support
uh making sure i don't miss any super
chats
it's hot in my room guys i might have to
check it off
mr lights please thanks again oh
infinity shades i saw
you stephen gaskin thanks for that super
chat infinity shades thanks for another
one spoiler new master 69 is the villain
can you imagine it'd be so funny kind of
like agatha when she's like and i killed
the dog too
at the end he's like and i'm new master
69 too how funny would that be
so oh some more strive hey what's up
it's tom big cuss family oh
no that's so funny uh peter colerton was
king foxhound not
my knowledge i i don't think so
not to my knowledge uh okay
okay okay
uh thanks for that super chat uh peter
uh mk gaming by munis what's up again
just stopping by as usual say hi
yep enjoy episode six can't wait for
your post show reactions inside
yeah i'm hey what's up andrew russell i
see you there
um man
i uh
i i hate i hate these finales i hate
when it's over
it's super exciting and it's super fun
but i you know it sucks when it's over
um corey holman have i liked the series
as a whole yes i think it's by far
the best thing to come from marvel since
uh phase four
cody barlow sings that super chat kevin
feige said that this was most important
series out of all them i agree and i
think that's because they're
establishing variants for spider-man
uh no way home and they're establishing
the multiverse for doctor strange
multiverse of madness and i think the
whole entire multiverse is about to
explode shane martin photo here since
one vision episode one nice
thanks for making the viewing experience
that much better the watch long
what would constitute an epic indian
well first and foremost thanks for
sticking around since uh one division
super appreciate that glad these uh
can help a little bit i think constitute
as an epic ending
would be like
a like a true god loki
or just a twist that we like really
aren't expecting and then at the end
it's
king like behind everything like
remember how loki worked for thanos in
the beginning
um i want kang to be lo this loki's
thanos
um mr lights please what if rin slayer
is a variant of king hey that could be
true you know that that could
that could definitely be something
marvel would do larva max 1258 thanks
for that super chat
no okay okay you guys are awesome
with the chat and with the super chat
you're all killing it got a lot of
people in here right now
a lot of love for loki i know it's for
lucky i know it's not for me you're not
fooling me
um i know i saw some i don't want to
miss any
i wonder if they're going to release it
like right on time tonight
dollar jack shafer thanks for the super
chat jack saver stop the sphere red cons
connect dots
we want rather than just like uh let
down to fist down no
adam brush or read richards just it
looks dumb
yeah i mean we're going to always
fantasize i guess fan fantasizes we're
always going to you know predict
the craziest things that come directly
from the comics you know
i think mephisto might have been a tad
bit of a reach but this one there's a
lot of evidence king
uh what type of credits you expect
ishmael thanks for that super chat
you take care as well and i expect kang
i i really do i mean we know he's coming
in ant-man three right so
there's no harm and showing him
gavin smith could it be a council of
kings teasing the post credits or
something
because he's worked with himself before
yeah totally uh someone mentioned that i
think in a few chats ago
that it could that you know the council
of the kings i definitely think so i'm
more leaning towards a mortise
um and then and then king the conqueror
being the main villain like mortis is
there and he's doing some stuff
uh you know the original timekeepers
came to him and asked him to help or
something like that they died
he's been the one behind it all perhaps
he's using a loki to help
and then the real kang is like out there
somewhere else
trevor hadley thanks for that big super
chat how do you think season two is
gonna start based on what we know right
now my theory is that if season two
comes out after our strange multiverse
madness
i think it's gonna include spider-man
and everyone at that possibly want to
well that would certainly be really
really cool
that would be a lot to throw in but then
again marvel's going pretty big so
they'd almost have to do a lot you know
what i mean so
uh yeah i wouldn't be surprised if it's
something like that it might have
something to do
with loki kind of enjoying the freedom
of being able to create other timelines
um so isaiah richardson
mr griffin was nathaniel richards though
right so yes it technically wasn't like
kang the conqueror because he didn't
deem himself that but
but mr griffin was nathaniel richards
and nathaniel richards is king
excuse me i'm sorry did i miss
what time is supposed to be released um
i mean in theory nine minutes but
they've released it early before
and i think it's out because a lot of
people are saying it's out uh i believe
i got all the super chats
if i miss them i am terribly sorry let's
go to disney plus right now
um and apparently it's out
i'm so sad that this is the end it's out
here we go for all time always 47
minutes
what gotta hit me with like an hour we
starting it right now
in three two one
boom we have started
i believe mr anderson will keep track of
the time if not
that's on me
we're just recapping right now
all right we're just recapping right now
so they they made they made sure to
mention that whatever
nexus event that loki and sylvie cause
could bring the whole place down
which is like yeah
let's do it boys and girls oh that part
was so awesome classic loki
was insane i loved his ability to do
that so we're still recapping
just a little recap and here we are
all right show me amazing things show me
amazing things
let's have a good finale wanda vision
finale was good the falcon and the
winter soldier for now it was okay
oh you here oh that's nice
puny god
here we go
we got the title screen and
oh look at this
okay so we have something
it looks like the universe uh yeah it's
like the universe
is exploding in into existence
there it is
what is pain oh here we are this has got
to be the timeline right
all right here we go
oh snap that looks epic look at that
guys i can't show much of the screen
because uh i can't i can't play the
audio because it'll uh
it'll get copyrighted actually my last
stream got copyrighted
so i can't show much
all right they're walking up to it
it's a very eerie castle
or at the door
they're here
all right they're going in
dang she said i was proven before you
even existed i just need a second to get
my head straight
oh the door open for them
there's hooded statues and it looks like
holy crap it is miss minutes
the citadel at the end of time
he's impressed who he who remains
wow and who is he
is only wow
test can you guys hear me
the battle of new york
i knew it she said how would you like to
win the battle of new york
you can kill them by the way we do talk
about spoilers in this guys it's a watch
party
miss minitz is just talking to them
right now telling them pretty much that
they could have anything they want
two loki's in the same place they could
go together
both of us together in a timeline
he could make it work he who remains
not buying it
miss minute said good luck with that
they're not buying it
so let's see who he who remains the one
that remains
is
actually actually is now we're back at
tba here's rinse layer
oh she sees the ring from mobius
he thinks this will be more useful this
minute says who
oh here we go
uh this episode's 47 minutes long
he remains they're talking about him
right now
here we go they're walking in a room
with a bunch of statues
one statue has fallen
looks like they're statues of the time
keepers
and one's fallen on the ground
and now another door is opening
oh here we go there's some something's
happening with the door
who is that
it's freaking king it's
freaking king
jonathan majors
it's freaking king
holy crap he who remains
she's still calling me that say it say
it
call yourself kang
let's talk he says in my office holy
frickin
crap let's go
look at that not what you were expecting
huh
gang it's king yeah let's start the
majors
don't tell me i'm a disappointment
whoa dodged him
dang he's like moving all around look at
that
you could teleport because he freaking
freaking can control time geez
dude what is the final fight gonna be
like look at this guy
he's freaking pouring them like tea this
is cool it's like a sanctum
it's like he's in a sanctum
so is that a mortise is it like which
king is it
dude this is like ridiculously cool
loki lookie oh my gosh how
epic look at that i mean
trying to show you guys all the good
parts look at this dude
freaking jonathan majors just
they still have their knives out and
he's just in there like dude i control
time you can't hurt me
so what happens
oh snap mobius has come back for rinse
layer
what's happening here with you two
now that we know your secret he has the
pen
and he says what did you do oh snap what
is this
oh it's oh what is happening
oh ohio 2018
oh snap what is happening i
wow okay
they're chasing b15
oh this this is her past life
that isn't judge rensselaer who is that
gang
loki's a flea on the back of a dragon
jonathan fricken majors as kang
dang he freaking just teleports and
let's get this out of the way what is he
going to do
i pull out a pulls out a book
you can't kill me because i already know
what's going to happen
pulls out a piece of paper that shows
everything that's happening
dude i actually
actually really love him as king
dude i actually love him
i know it all i've seen it all
dude jonathan majors is perfect
every step you took
i paved interesting king paved the road
for him to get there
for them to get there
wow his character is just really awesome
oh he has the rest of their story
hahaha
finish the quest
he said silva do you think you can trust
loki
now rinse layer
mobius wants free will for everybody
then you sent me to die
well jonathan majors is confirmed to be
playing kang whether this is
that same king and ant-man 3 i don't
know but it's a it's a variant of
kang
eons of friendship dang they've been
around for a live oh
wow
oh mobius is the goat we can't take away
people's free will
oh where you going
oh snap mommy says i'm not letting you
go
what's happening here she says you're of
no danger to me
why is she a variant of king too or is
she king's lover
she's going to meet kang
going in search of free war wow
what dude this guy's epic
he just said he's afraid of himself
and who are you i've been dubbed many
names
say it a ruler
a conqueror
he who remains a jerk
nathaniel
it's not as simple as a name
dude you're gonna show are you gonna
show us your past
oh my gosh please show me your past
eons ago
it's nathaniel richards eve
dude it's literally
they make contact with each other wow
dude this guy's perfect as kang
they shared technology and knowledge
but something happened right
not every version of me is good
so pure part
new lands to be conquered
the peace between realities erupted into
war look at that
chase
did the timekeepers come to you
and then the timekeepers came
[Laughter]
tell me tell me king no time keepers to
come along
goliath
he harnessed goliath
he says he ended the multiversal war
by weaponizing a life
and then he created the tv
dude this guy's epic
hence you're welcome
you came to kill the devil my festo
i think i'm able to just wait
till you meet his variance wow
and that's the game but
dude
this is crazy
i've left a million lifetimes
she so we called him a liar
he offered them a job two options
okay
kill kang there's an infinite amount of
kings
or sylvie and loki run the tva
wow
he says he's tired that's why he'd give
up control
this game is for the young
this is so good
multiverse of war if they kill him or
the two of them take over
grow up
grow up sylvie
we're all villains here this is
no way
oh this is so good
something's happening they hear
something they feel something
he's he something's happening
we just crossed the threshold
and kang is happy about it
he just dropped something and now he
looks confused
i fibbed
he said he knew everything up to a
certain point
and that point was until 10 seconds ago
so what happens now
oh snap oh
[Music]
a bunch of branches are being created
and he doesn't know how the rest is
gonna go
spoilers coming guys spoilers coming
guys
an infinite amount of king will
reincarnation interesting
no line of manipulation
what is kang up to
that's his device took it off
hmm he loves
all the honesty
what you doing there buddy he's got the
device
on his hand and what is happening
i feel like stuff needs to start
happening or we're not going to have
enough time
oh
sophia was going to kill kang
oh step well here's the fight
looking silvie
boogie man
the timeline's branching
you want the throne she says
what was i thinking trust you don't do
it till silvie
dang
you can't trust and i can't be trusted
so we wait now they're fighting
ah hey freaking king is just watching
tank
i think silvia's a little bit more
skilled than loki
sweet this is an epic magical fight
this is
ah i love this but i hate it
there's that good old scene from the
trailer that's edited out
what did she just do to him
here we go here we go
dang
come on what is happening
okay
oh no he's crying
spoilers right here i'm doing spoilers
you ready and
kissing and gang is watching
dude does that create the nexus of it
but i'm not you
oh snap she threw loki back
oh no
dang
oh crap that's epic
oh
i'll see you soon oh snap
oh crap
all right guys i'm going to talk
spoilers in like 10 seconds
so leave if you don't want them
she just killed kang a variant of him
look at that crap wow
she sent loki away and then killed
kang and now what happens
holy crap and there oh look at that
and all the branches are being created
and multiverse of
madness oh
a lot of branches are being created
whole oh branches off of branches are
being created holy crap
wow branches outs
branches out of branches oh my gosh
there's so many branches and here comes
secret wars look at that
for all time
always dude
oh my boy
my boy
so sad he loved sylvie he loved her
he's genuinely sad
oh no
a smile because this was the plan all
along
no i'm gonna do something
where is the mobius jetski
all right loki has a mission i don't
know what it is but he has one
according to the armory
so is he gonna
63 new branches
we can't stop it
we freed the timeline
someone is coming countless different
versions are coming
what is about to happen wait what
who does he see oh it's already changed
look it's him
oh my gosh
holy crap what
[Music]
what is that
is there no there's no post credit scene
loki will return it season two
it just said loki will return in season
two
wow look at this loki will return
in season two i will freaking show
everybody right now look at this
loki will return in season two
thank goodness because wow
oh my gosh
that's really it no post credit scene
huh
oh wow holy crap
i love that
wow
wow
i gotta take this off guys i'm sweating
so much
i don't know when season two is they
haven't even started filming it yet
but oh my gosh
oh
waiting on chris to get in
wow wow
holy crap and that's what
yeah oh man
i can't believe i actually
like called this from the first episode
like
and i was right like it wasn't
it was so good yeah i can't see you
i'm blown away and it was amazing and
good dude i
from the very first freaking episode i
called king i called king
and i freaked out uh
everyone thinks i'm talking to myself
because they can't see christopher
i'm here i'm here i'm just trying to
breathe i'm thank you for the super chat
jake
uh i can buy some ibuprofen i
i don't like it i don't like it
i didn't like the ending i loved it i'm
struggling
it was great it was cool the reveal was
super cool
dude it was all um oh man
so i loved how they made kang
i don't know if this is how gang is
super cool he's freaking awesome i don't
know if the water
is gonna be i'm sweating
i mean i think so he was pretty adamant
and confident that he will be coming
back
i guess like he's like like he
seems to know the time loop of it all
you know
i mean he did say at the end though that
he hadn't seen past that part
no but maybe it goes back maybe he said
i'll he did say i'll end up ready i'll
see you soon he goes i'll end up right
back here you know so it's a time loop
i can't i can't fathom how i mean it was
so
well laid out at the end
oh man my brain is just blown by that
ending and we already kind of knew it
was going to be kang and everything but
just the way it all ended and the way it
just left us
sitting there without answers is just
affecting me
in a painful way
i i'm glad because season two
right um
but well is it coming out next week
because i don't know how long i can
it's not coming out next week but my
mind is blown
um absolutely but i will say
i will say this they scared me
i did the fight scene when they were
fighting
no yes but i was terrified that she was
gonna kill loki
yeah that's what i when they were i was
terrified that that was gonna happen
but no like the threat of king actually
scares me
how he's pretty much like yo i'm the guy
and there's gonna be millions of me
coming
and that i'm just kind of like you know
they've called me mentor
many names conqueror like
[Music]
you know what though wait wait hold a
second hold on just a second
literally everybody warren and i were
having dinner right before sitting at
the same table talking and we did say
exactly this
and i wish it was recorded if it's doom
imagine this line what did we say
imagine if they go to kill doom and he
says
i'll just win it again i'll just be
right back here
yeah and that's exactly what happened it
just wasn't doomed pretty much yeah
a hundred percent we had that
conversation imagine how cool the line
would be if doom was like
i won the secret war once i'll do it
again
that's exactly what happened though
pretty much except not doom
i know king jay thanks for that super
chat how come loki is the only one who
remembers
because i think kang has already invaded
the tva
oh i think he went to a different
timeline yeah it's just
i'm a crime blown away dude trevz all
king was already reincarnated by the end
his statue in the place
of the og dime keepers yep kang has
kang is there uh jonathan granada's now
that
we have a multiverse do you think robert
downey jr ever come back maybe different
iron man especially
since three spiders come in yeah i think
he'll return in secret wars for
for a cameo for sure thanks for watching
one no post credit scene cosmo i love
you thank you evil can't gonna be op
yes i i'm so happy lone wolf what up we
just witnessed the multiverse of madness
mind blown we sure did
don't worry guys stick marzel brings out
a great point don't worry
ant-man and the wasp are gonna take care
of it
i don't even know what's going on i do
know one thing
[Laughter]
no i can't i don't wanna wait
i'm ready now they didn't really answer
it
anything if it was in the um
quantum realm it didn't i don't think it
was i think you were right it's probably
limbo
yeah see jenkins alright shows toby and
andrew already i know right i mean they
basically just
confirmed it i was hoping the
post-credits scene would be like doc ock
in
in tom holland's world something they
didn't give us anything
not even a post-credits scene great
episode but where was king loki well
there is a post-credits scene no there's
not a post credits
uh in your chat are saying there is um
they're trolling there's a post credit
scene that says loki will return into
episode two oh that doesn't king loki
was not there because my initial theory
that i
kind of stuck to the whole entire time
i was a little split that i might see i
was a little split that i might see
you know king loki at the end but uh
i was telling chris today i was like
there's just too much for kang
there's no way he's not behind at all
like
i'm not surprised i'm definitely not
disappointed you know what a big
cliffhanger was
a red slayer red slayer where the heck
did she go
yeah i don't think
oh man in hell maybe she's a variant of
kang and she freaking is in the tva
screwing stuff up right now too i mean
who freaking knows this
i mean at this point literally
anything is possible now yeah anything
you put any thought or idea iron man
returns
12 000 spider-man in one way anything is
possible following what just happened
that's the cool thing and that's why
kevin feige said that loki is gonna be
the most important
project for anything i mean it literally
everything that happens from here on out
with the exception of maybe like hawkeye
and miss marvel and stuff because that
could that could technically happen
before
all this all the time is linear i don't
know um
this affects everything um ren slayer
pulled a white vision
that's funny she did colin bissonnette
he wasn't affected because he was at the
end of time who
who
king oh yeah that's i guess that's a
good point he wasn't in fact because at
the time king james did you see deadpool
mcs i did it's hilarious
uh bradley jones biggest cliffhanger
where's mobius's jet ski well i'm hoping
at the end of season two that's where
we're gonna get it
geez we don't know anything about season
two timeline or anything i don't know
anything i you know what
what like where would a loki 2 season
fit in that it makes sense because if
doctor strange is dealing with the
multiverse of madness and we're still
waiting for loki season 2 i mean he
can't fix this on his own
no and i think a lot's gonna happen in
between i don't think we're getting loki
season two for
at least a year out unfortunately but is
all that stuff gonna be multiverse stuff
no i think hawkeye miss marvel stuff
like that it's not gonna be multiverse
stuff but then i think you're gonna have
your very very
huge heavy impact mcu films spider-man
no way home
multiverse of madness columbus not loki
uh yeah loki that's okay yeah good point
for that he wasn't affected because he
was at the end of time but everybody
else
thanks jake i guess i guess the tva does
exist somewhere right and they were
affected
and i i think kang has already taken
over the tv i think that's what happened
um guys i gotta use the bathroom so i'm
gonna leave you chris to entertain you
for a second
oh i'm gonna entertain him right now i'm
entertaining
all right force ah my brain is broken
all right i'm doing it what's up
everybody i'm chris and i
had my mind blown i'm told to go to 42
38 so that's what i'm doing right now
42 38 let's see what happens there
um well guys i'm i'm blown away by what
just happened
i we we had a big big impression that it
was gonna be king so i'm not surprised
by the fact that it was king
i like the way they did it the way they
introduced him
the way that they showed him the way
that he was as a character
i'm not seeing a post-credits scene oh
wait there is one no way
oh no it's loki will return okay it's
kind of a post credit scene but not
really
um so i mean this leaves us with an
open opportunity for
anything to happen guys i mean anything
marvel wants to do here forward
they're going to have an open window to
do it i don't know how long that's going
to last they can introduce
x-men from different universe they can
introduce i mean literally
anything is possible moving on from here
and i am so excited
to see what direction they take for this
and what they have happened i'm so
excited right now
i i think marvel
hold on strife this is the best indian
out of all the disney plush shows i
would agree with that i think this
is the best show around around the whole
thing yeah and i think
i seriously think
this is what i've been waiting for the
uh one division was fantastic
the falcon which soldier was good this
just like took the mcu to another level
so for everybody who was like phase four
sucks because it's not your typical mcu
this is you no it's not this is yours
even more crazy mcu now and uh
yeah team nasty nelson thanks for super
chat you're in the loki twilight zone
all right so just a fun question
obviously you haven't had a lot of time
to think about it so just off the top of
your head
multiverse is blown up
what do you want to see come out of that
do you want to see them introduce the
x-men
what a new iron man what would be like
if warren was in charge of mcu
for the next week what would you be
implementing now that you have the
window of the multiverse
if i'm fighting okay
um sure
doesn't even have to make sense just
what would you love to see now come to
life that the multiverse is open and you
can literally do anything
i would like to see the the most
powerful villains from each universe
come together
and i would like to see the most
powerful heroes from all the universes
come together
and fight that'd be crazy which is
essentially secret wars
uh right and that's what it is building
too
but i would i would start introducing
i would i would all these different
champions from different universes i
would make it a normality
in the mcu right now of a bunch of
different variants of other characters
popping up right now hold on
so you know some super chat says hey
richard before go for it marvel just up
their game hell yeah they broke disney
plus
pattern defeating the villain at the end
since look he's a villain two films look
at the best series yeah i mean this was
fantastic and they really did give him
a real villain who's not defeated
jonathan granada's my hat goes off to
fighting yeah he's built when no one
else can
wait for season two mind blown the way
they introduced him was epic dude kang
was amazing
i mean kang was amazing i the character
was awesome
he was ep and jonathan majors killed it
you know and like people kept saying
like they announced some frank man he's
not going to show up and
loki i told you well it's funny because
i
i wasn't 100 sure it was him and before
i'm sitting there going it's kang
that's why i ran to your room i'm like
because people are like who is that i'm
like i think it's jonathan majors who's
going to be playing kang but i know who
will 100
know so i'ma go ask him real quick
oh my gosh
trevor hadley what do you think sylvie's
doing at the end of time i'm coming back
later for you i mean she was just
sitting there
and soaking in the fact that what she's
been trying to do
her whole life for
ever right because no time is
finally done but it's not loki was right
you know what if he's not lying what if
so many horrible freaking things come
from this which which
happened happy tron d11 thanks for super
chat little drag my guys so when do you
anticipate knowing home trailer will
come out now
uh probably a couple weeks in between
uh what if and now all my pal best
disney plus
episode out did such a good ending did
service con for comic fans
and mcu fans mind blown heck yeah and
they really did i liked how that like
kang explained like his story and he's
like there was the
you know one of us brad thank you for
joining uh how you doing uh
so it's half right king was the person
trying to stop the other king
cat cassie was a yeah i mean essentially
yeah he's trying to stop all the other
ones and he really did want loki and
them to take over
which is kind of crazy uh t nasty nelson
the king loki's for red herons yeah
do we we didn't even see that
scene that's so true
uh abatron d11 my only problem is like
if someone hasn't or can't see loki
then how will they understand any movies
going forward
yeah no kevin feige did say like you're
gonna have to watch these shows moving
forward
he straight up said that like you you're
gonna have to
watch these shows you're gonna have to
or you're not gonna know what's going on
that's so true though we didn't even see
that's so true we didn't even see
so it's exciting that you know all these
characters still remain
and will be returning you know mobius
and owen wilson's coming back
sylvie's coming back you know none of
them are really gone
they're all there right no one died i
mean i mean king dude
but diddy the post credit scene is
called ant-man of the lost quantum media
that's funny and true i mean oh oh
holy crap i
i'm at a loss i mean i'm just
it's just crazy to me that we have this
and it's funny because we knew it was
going this direction like
i'm not surprised by what happened i'm
just trying to comprehend what happened
and and what that really does mean for
marvel moving forward it is
unlimited potential now and it's
exciting it really is i'm excited
yeah jabber 27 how happy am i about
being right about kang
um i'm very happy but not just because i
can say i'm right
um i'm happy because it makes sense and
the way they pulled it off
was to me very intense
and yeah it just seems like it's just
kind of like
they're building him up like he's super
super like obviously this is a guy who
just
created the tv i can control everything
you know imagine what somebody more
evil than him could do pirate man that
was king just not named jonathan major
is kang and amanda was yep
i mean he did say they've called me many
things you know conqueror
you know all that stuff i mean jerk a
jerk yeah
uh king jay thanks for super chat do you
i think the new evil kang will be blue i
hope so i hope it's pretty accurate like
that
jonathan sanchez did kang confirm
reincarnation on the mcu
uh kind of
but like in like a
time way right i don't know if i can
explain that right now
uh robert soriano so technically with
that episode andrew and tobia
confirmed i mean yeah i've uh
i've talked to sources and i've they've
told me like yes 100
let's confirm alexa hey welcome
thanks for the super chat i'm very happy
with the indian i'm glad disney pulled
mephisto with kang thank you so much for
making experience more enjoyable
it's been such a great ride i'm
definitely going to miss live streams
thank you so much thanks for
for joining each stream and the live
streams have been great chris and i have
really enjoyed them
thank you um and we'll do live streams
uh until
what if comes out and then we'll start
doing them at night again
but with all you guys it's pretty pretty
easy jonathan granada so wait mobius was
looking at the monitor of my split then
loki came back to a different tv8 does
that mean they're two
tva og moby somewhere else
uh i think rin slayer did something
i think she was definitely working with
kang right we can't ignore their
relationship
in in the comics and and she basically
did confirm
like that she knew
kind of who she who he was you know so
we can't ignore that
i i definitely think i think she was
somewhat aware
and i think she might have done
something to me but i think kang has
just come in
uh you still have to remember he is the
master of time travel
uh warren i think they're hearing me
through your door you might need to
close it
no i don't hear you no your chat is i
think your chat is
uh c jenkins knowing home is about to be
all out fun and nostalgic yeah
for real i mean yes thanks for the super
chat i will close my door in a second
after i acknowledge all the super chats
incredible tom thanks for that super
chat spider-man trailer within a week or
two
no later willing to take bets no i i
probably agree with you on that one
i i say it's coming uh king j
that was super chat now that there's
multiverse does this explain
red guardian fighting captain american
80s no
they actually kind of explained that
he's kind of crazy
and that he kind of has a uh
problem like separating reality from
like his thoughts and stuff like that
was kang wanda's big big bad like she
pulled her kids from timeline
and can hear and tap into other
universes that's a great thought
honey graham thanks for that super chat
but no i don't think so because i think
since she created them
they're taken out from her when she you
know released
everybody but i do think that she
actually created souls
so they're still alive somewhere
who knows maybe mephista is gonna come
after all
um
asraelius escanorius i think we'll get
multiple versions of kang throughout the
next big mcu film starting with doctor
strange i 100 agree
100 agree on that and then he's getting
a pretty big appearance on uh
on uh i am in the last quantomania
yes nelson gonna miss these watch
parties until the 11th yeah definitely
gonna miss the watch parties they're
always super fun we'll do some live
streams in between
but the watch parties are are the best
avatar on d11 when the comic series gets
too expanded and convoluted they usually
breed it right so after mcu gets his
base it can get
what else a reboot it's a possibility
but
i'm trusting kevin feige and the people
over at marvel studios right now
i mean how incredible
is all this i mean like you know
i think they're doing an insanely good
job
and i i really just think
i don't think they're going to run out
of ideas in all honesty and i i think
rebooting
is a very very far way out uh randy
burnside this was a great episode
he will have blue masculine three time
gideon and
emmy kanga oh yeah he definitely tom
did amazing and so did sylvie um sophia
i mean oof
how insane right how house just so good
let me make sure to miss any super chats
luis camacho we are in the multiverse
sylvian loki
are stuck in crazy versus what dimension
is loki stuck in now
and will our mobius find our loki
yeah so that's kind of confusing isn't
at the end is it a different
dimension of the tva
are there more than one tv i don't think
there is more than one tv i think kang
is already infiltrated somehow
but we'll have to wait and see haiti
thanks for the super chat did look nick
did loki technically happen before one
division is that why wanda didn't get
caught by the tva
is that why she can get her kids down so
many questions
and rinslayer will she fall for a kang
variant
yeah i definitely think she's going to
fall for a king variant make an
excellent point
about this happening before one division
and that's why
all her stuff you know tva never stepped
in
it's weird because the tva is clearly
still around right
um but they look to be under different
direction now so
love to see about that but i think yeah
i think it could have happened
before corey coleman what was the
message did king send to ravana
i'm not sure i'm gonna have to look into
that um
but it's clear they know each other
right i mean it's very clear
so i think there's big things to be had
here i think ren slayer
i think ren slayer
did something at the end of that as part
of the whole mobius doesn't know who she
is and stuff like that
you know what i mean like
yeah uh danny bello thinks about super
chat
so that's gonna be
for she-hulk is the leader going to be
in it uh i'm not sure i
haven't really heard much about that yet
but with loki i would say anything is
possible so here's
chris here's like a situ not a situation
here's
here's an issue that i think marvel
might run in with now
i'm not trying to crap on any other
series but like after this
what is she-hulk gonna be like you know
and hawkeye going to be like because
they're going to be more
hawkeye is definitely going to be more
grounded so
what's going to happen it's going to be
crazy philip column
thanks for that super chat so
what do we you know how
i just fear that a lot of people aren't
going to be able to go watch hawkeye
after this
i mean how do you watch hawkeye after
that i think you have to start and i've
been saying this for
like when was in game like two years ago
at this point like
jeez yeah i mean we got lucky well not
necessarily lucky but
you know these other shows got lucky
because of the huge break after end game
pretty much came out
you know you were desperate for anything
marvel but you know how do you watch
this
and then go oh yeah let's see what
hawkeye's up to over here
no there's nothing just hawkeye or
anybody that likes it but it's not as
exciting right it's not
yeah you can't convince me that it is
yeah
difference but difference between
different universes
reality i drop
i drop hose thanks for that super chat
and laugh with your name
um i'm not quite sure what you're asking
um but yeah i mean essentially the
differences between the universes they
are different realities right
um when reality has iron man that's
still alive another one doesn't you know
uh
i think it's all about to go down i
think we're about to see it
nicolas hernandez so was there multiple
versions of mobius at the end
was there just that version of mobius
that was talking to loki in the end i
i think it's just that version and you
know something's happened
kang is infiltrated in some way um
we saw the statue right and i think that
was the big reveal i think it was that
he's already taken over there's no more
time keepers there's only kang because
you have to think of it so essentially
the kang that was killed at the end was
good
yeah he seemed like he was great he was
good he did
bad things to be good well i loved it
when he looked at him he's like come on
we're all villains here right exactly he
understood his assignment he knew what
he was doing what he was doing
but he knew why he was doing it he told
somebody
oh man because he knows he's like you
don't know me
right i know the other me's are going to
come so
i just think that the one of the other
me's has already
has risen to power already and he's in
charge of tva
and who knows what i mean they clearly
have wiped the memories of the
variants before it's not that hard right
they could do it again
and that's why he doesn't know him i
believe
and thanks for the super chat oh man a
lot to wrap your head around i will say
that a lot
it is a lot as i'm sitting here like
trying to like talk and everything like
to like really bring to
reality the implications of what we just
saw
i mean kevin feige undersold it when he
was like oh yeah loki's going to change
the future of the emcee you really did
undersell it
yeah like it's a little bit more than
that like
he destroyed like everything the future
is whatever now it's it's
nutty well shane martin photo good point
will the in-game years from now
be to contain the timeline to one branch
or will timeline always be multi i think
you know eventually
we're going to have another all-out
multiverse war and that's going to be
the next end game which is secret wars
and that's going to be all about getting
those timelines back in order
thomas j floyd and then however that
ends is going to be that's going to be
insane
that's gonna be crazy because then again
they can start over fresh i think
cosmic entities come in at that point
and that's i mean how do you even not
have i mean
yeah i i would actually love to see
thanos return in battle world and fight
it out as
like thanos that would be super cool to
see because something we didn't really
get
was a lot of thanos combat
which is pretty incredible and i would
love to see some thanos combat against
maybe we'll get the hulk thanos re
re-match you know
right yeah and it could be world breaker
hulk and who even there are so many
options
i'm not worried about marvel running out
of ideas thomas j flores
hey love the fact that look and still be
finally kissed yes
and she'll just smashed my heart and
shocked me at the same time
it was definitely the best so far i'd
agree with you thanks for that super
chat very generous super chat
teenacy now saying herbana's 2013 hulk
cannon now scene
seems like it like everything's canon
now it's not that hard to make
everything cannon now
jeremiah miller disney has loki set
before wanda and the falcon i'm confused
as why we didn't see an indication of
multiverse in those shows
i think it might be because they don't
know right
maybe they don't know but also this
takes place outside of time
right so when it takes place who knows
as an absolute you know fan of marvel
and you know
i know their track breaker is really
good we don't really have anything to
worry about but just to poke the thought
at it
are you at all worried that this ends up
just getting too complicated and
becoming too much
and harder for fans to grasp
you don't think no i think they're dude
in a really good way
so does this make what if cannon
and if it does i mean it may mean we're
probably getting
those mcu jumping the shark and getting
boring no i don't think it's gonna get
boring at all i think of anything
chris kind of just made a point that
it's going to be so much that you're
going to be like whoa
slow down a little bit what you know
what's what's going after um
i didn't see anyone guess we'd see a
version of nathaniel richards as the one
who remains only king
which he wasn't crazy stuff uh i i did
say in one video
it could be the one who remains um
was that in the last breakdown chris i
did say that i said it at one point
it was it was like a week or so ago i
wasn't like i think it's this one i said
this is also a possibility i mean he
wasn't not
kang right he was nothing even said i've
been called a conqueror you know it's
like
right he comes right you can pick his
except this i believe this was like a
mortise this was like a good one
right although he did say the time
keepers weren't real
um but this is this was nathaniel
richards
and he says i've been called king
because
maybe different variant of him has or
i've been called conquer well maybe even
him you know how long he's probably been
around to be
oh forever right puppet man he's lived
so many different lifetimes and again
and this
brings me back to what he was saying at
the end and we were talking about his
confidence
that he's going to end up right back
there you know he knows
the knowledge of this character the
understanding of time that
where our minds are breaking right now
just trying to even comprehend
is gonna be really cool to see down the
line and i don't think we don't see this
exact version
of kang no i don't think it's the same
exact person
but i don't think you don't get that
same persona that same capability that
same knowledge i definitely think that's
gonna happen
you know we're going to see that again
oh for sure
marvel geek thank you for the super chat
what if kang was preventing mutants
i mean very very positive one reality is
you've all ruben route hey warren love
all streams thank you they've been great
when king offered lucky the job takeover
i thought king loki
have many more thoughts and theories i'd
love to talk to you about them for sure
um i have a discord it's in the about me
section
of my youtube channel join it
i don't want to miss any super chats so
let me let me grab them real quick
yeah yeah let me know when you're done
uh
bradley jones do you think thor love and
thunder will make thor and jane two
different variants
no i it's it's our jane
uh do you think the eternals fit into
this if they do
man it's really hard to tell with that
movie you know um
where it's at it's gonna be everywhere
so you know what exactly is going to be
going on but i think yes in some way
shape or form
yes i do uh devin headdress spider-man
trailer incoming multiverse and matt's
going to be
insane i jumped out of my seat when i
saw jonathan majors yeah i freaked out
too
and yeah this is it we're in it now
we're in the multiverse thanks super
chat
peyton fob thanks for that super chat
super appreciate that garrett bridges
do you think kang will be showing up in
both multiverses of madness and quantum
mania
how do you think this will affect what
if series
is all the what-if scenarios canon now
so
there's a report that says you know the
what-if series are going to somewhat
affect the mcu and i think really
anything is possible now
to be perfectly honest which is exciting
nick reid what's up with spider-man home
cast right now
uh i'm telling you toby and andrew are
going to be in it all my sources have
told me that they're 100 going to be in
it
that's all i got for you
peyton fob again how will the
thunderbolts anti-heroes
forming play do you think um i still
think we're gonna have a grounded part
of the mcu you know
um and i think that's where they're at
you can't
you it's like chris was saying you can't
go so far out there
that it's too much and i don't think
marvel has really done that
on screen yet this was probably the
closest they've got with having all
these different variants and stuff like
that
um but i think we all can see now why
we've been waiting so long for the
spider-man noah trailer this clearly had
to happen before
you know right chris don't you agree
sorry repeat the question
it's very clear why we don't have the
spiderman no way home trailer
because oh i mean i had to see this
before this had to have happened because
of course we're sitting there asking you
know like
i mean every single fan art of you
google
right now any of you guys spider-man no
way home
spider-verse fan art every single one of
it is doctor strange opening the portal
right you know right that's not that's
not even
close to required right now you know
like anything these timelines crashing
into each other
and all of that you know our minds were
so tunnel vision to oh doctor strange is
heavily involved with
it's all bets are off
i will say i was told yesterday
what the actual plot of spiderman away
home was
and i believe it because it comes a very
incredible source
and i'll say this in one of my videos
i have discussed it i titled it plot
leak or something like that
good there's only like 12. i was gonna
say so good luck
go re-watch my videos one of them's real
um actually a lot of different pieces of
a lot of the plot leaks
like together are real but there is one
where like i straight up state the plot
of it well because between different
cast members who get little pieces of it
and then
different workers eventually it does all
add up to one crazy bit
yeah but you know i
i can't understate and i've said it too
many times already just the
insane leg room that marvel gave
themselves just now
oh kevin feige is literally pulling on
one of these right now
this guy is like he can do whatever he
wants
and it makes perfect sense
the master deadpool sitting on a couch
with a cord
it all makes sense there's no
questioning
do you think they'll try and use this as
a way to get venom in the mcu actually
kevin fight and king of summer since fed
super [ __ ] actually kevin feige recently
said he's open to it
it's just a matter of when and how if it
makes sense
to nasty nelson in some timeline we are
all superheroes that is so true
and i hope you're a good one and not
like uh homelander
uh the spiderdragon984 what if that's
how ralph boner was in one division
yeah i mean there's a scenario where
that exists but
i think agatha made it pretty clear that
she kind of
enchanted him and kind of controlled him
although he was the witness protection
guy i think so
we'll see what happens there
uh belief 789
what's the object king picks up and
drops on the table after
they pass the threshold was you just
testing the crime pattern is still
working
yeah no no no i i saw that yeah you know
i was wondering about that too i think
that's what he was
testing if you know gravity was really
working if the universe was shattered
i think he was definitely testing to see
if
i would excuse me i would say like
universal laws are still the same
thank you for the super chat senor jake
do you think that we won't see loki
until season two because kang will
capture loki in the new tva he is in
um not necessarily because he's gonna
get captured and warren can give you his
opinion on this too
but i just think he's gonna be he's
still outside of time
yeah right he's still in the tva he's
still outside of time you know he's not
going to just show up and thor love and
thunder like hey what's up thor
you know he's he's outside of time but
the other thing is you know
hey it's greg i was right
there it is yes i was right it's great
and um
you never really know hey greg not that
you can hear me
wasn't it crazy cool
thank you
i stuck it thank you
thank you very much all right
see ya great from the river
that's pretty cool phone call sorry real
quick as i know these super chats are
gonna disappear
uh josh is a gamer one two three didn't
get mobius from jet ski season two it's
coming
oh he's still alive though well i
thought we weren't going to see mobius
after this i thought he was going to
ride his
his jetseakee into the sunset so i'm
actually okay with that because we're
going to get more mobius i'm okay with
this i
like i want another season i'm happy
with this i'm happy with this
rittwick john what's up my mind is like
scott lang and in game what the hell
good night thank you dan kang is here
secret wars event because time has
wrecked
was this kang a variant too fed up of
wars i think this was a good king who
was doing what he had to do
war the infinity war what do they do
well keep in mind
that the eternals exist in time
and if kang has control of things
outside of time he's stronger
so i believe other variants of them
fought in the war and maybe they're
aware of it
but as far as the movie we're going to
see not too sure
uh strife no way home trailer coming out
tomorrow morning i hope i
i would not count on that because
tomorrow is technically when the episode
releases
you know it'll be at least a couple days
so that the loki i think it'll be a
couple days they're definitely going to
want some couple high
also like i interviewed task master for
black widow
today and those videos like coming out
tomorrow and stuff like that too so
they're not going to take away from the
promotion of black widow as
well uh so i think we have a little bit
maybe a week or two i would say
i really appreciate you and warren it's
been pretty fun coming here to listen to
you guys after every episode my
girlfriend and i love
hearing the theories well it looks like
warren's uh working on getting his
podcast going again so hopefully we can
keep getting some shows going out
and uh thank you for joining i'm glad
you and your girlfriend have been
enjoying it
we're having a blast with you guys we
actually love going live
yeah you know it's fun to interact with
you guys and to answer your questions
and
really to get to know the fans of not
just marvel but of
you know the work we guys we we do as
well so it's it's actually a lot of fun
and thank you for joining uh i gotta
bust a few super jets out chris
go for it let me know came in late but
what do you guys think kings
come back and low-key too after dr
strange's movie or what oh for sure
and i think we're gonna see him in more
than just a doctor strange movie man
i i really do jp do you think agatha was
talking about kang when she warned wanda
about a great evil that was coming
uh no i i don't i think she was talking
about mephisto um
or somebody else i really think now that
wanda
okay what's up i think now that wanda
being next to bean means
she's the key of all this maybe she's
the only one who can race nexus events
yeah that's a great thought man
uh eric 23 everybody is saying check out
knowing homecast has been updated
uh if it's what i've been reading it is
daredevils in it and i know that matt
murdock is
i've been i shouldn't say i know i have
been told by a very incredible source
that he is going to be lawyer
not daredevil but matt murdock jabber 27
hopefully tax master can be redone in
the future mcu you see that's where i
kind of differ
like differentiate my opinion between
everybody else because i think if they
didn't reveal
taskmaster to be who taxmaster is no
spoilers
everybody would have been fine like if
taskmaster kept their mask on the entire
movie
i don't think i think people had been
like taskmaster was cool
but some people didn't like what they
did and i understand that
but i think it's fine colin bassinet
look at yeah daredevil yeah
i think it's matt murdock though um
and guys i sincerely apologize if i miss
any super chats
uh mr anderson or if will you let me
know if i miss any please
um my mind is drawing a blank
who the heck is the guy always talked
about in uh
in one division not mephisto the other
guy
nightmare who created the book uh
sharon chatham c'thun
whatever freaking guy that everyone else
kept saying i was pronounced wrong uh
anger says toby and andrew and garfield
is in the film you can't trust imdb and
you can't trust google somebody's
telling me there's a
morbius trailer with him in what
chris i need you to watch the morbius
trailer all of you tobey maguire
spiderman is in it
is that the thing on the wall i don't
know if it's a new trailer they're
referring to just
i'm watching the morbius trailer yeah i
feel like we would have seen it by now
so i'm going to say
yes that is an older trailer but uh yeah
yeah uh andrew s uh be careful with imdb
and like google and stuff because
yeah it's like the wikipedia of the
oh no movie just hold on some super
chats just like went away where'd they
go here we go
uh adi ahadi it looks like
uh who else you got out here killing him
so he can roll the tv loki is a trick oh
he does have celebrated bracelet now
though to control everything yes she has
the bracelet but she's not using it
and if she were i mean
the multiverse wouldn't have fallen into
absolute chaos though
i just think she has control of the
chaos now well to an excellent
i guess uh audi makes a good point that
says loki tricked sylvia into killing
him so that he could rule the tva
look he's a trick i mean kang already
ruled the tva though
i'm just saying this yeah i just think
kang was confident that he'll be back
you know reincarnation baby like he he
understands
time travel he understands time loops in
a way that hasn't been explained to us
yet
we can't understand it chicken sticks
thanks for that super chat appreciate it
the oz log toby and andrew definitely
variants right
can we expect more spider people how
would they get in and shout out to
segopub the homie yeah they're variants
technically right so like we kept
calling them like different versions of
you know
uh spider-man they're all variants and
and that's why loki had to happen
well now nobody's a very nobody hum i
mean or they're
all very
uh
t nasty nelson am i reading this again
do i think the leaders in she-hulk
um i believe i answered you before if it
didn't i apologize
i'm not sure i haven't heard anything
about that um
and i usually you know hear a lot of
stuff like that so
i'll ask around for you oh man
the implications of everything and this
right here
mk super chat doctor strange two is
going to be a hell for everyone i mean
yeah like chris was saying like
i mean essentially you know what's crazy
is like doctor strange two is gonna be a
scary movie
and i love it right so it's like what's
going i might have to report it to
warren the multiverse uh
you might have to what to me i'm gonna
have to get you like eight tubs of
popcorn to go watch it that's good
watch me know what i'll watch you think
marvel ritwik chew on we didn't see the
scene loki standing stark towers and
glory yeah i know i
uh they just totally red herring does
says somebody said
here's here's a fun one you know
the the multiverse has exploded whatever
there's going to be a either a
multiversal war
or a different version of kang taking
over
who's strong enough or what team is
going to be strong enough to take that
down or what
multiple characters you know 10 iron
mans what's strong enough to take down
this kang because he was terrifying and
he was a good guy
he was i i believe he was good um and he
was terrifying
yeah that's a big one right so you're
gonna have to
start to get you know in my mind um
franklin richards the the son of reed
richards and sue storm
an omega level mutant could do the job
and we're gonna need mutants to be in
here and i still think you know i don't
think 2023
battle world begins you know i still
think we're years out from that we're
totally used out for
six seven years but it is gonna be so
mind-blowing as the movies bend in and
out of different timelines now
i mean it's almost gonna be like it's
almost like what dc's been trying to do
with their different batman's and all
this but they did it backwards whereas
now it's like hey we're going to open it
up and you're going to know that and
you're not going to have to guess what
world everything exists in
and it's organized and
i don't know it's gonna be it's gonna be
crazy yeah
i mean they could start a whole new iron
man trilogy they could start right
anything i mean
roger thanks for super chat says marvel
vs dc confirmed i mean
they could do that if they wanted to i'm
not gonna
say that's gonna happen but they have
the logic set
up to do it which is crazy it would make
sense
right you can't you know yeah um
luke lill it'll be such a good
mess when we see variant for each of the
next films shows they merge
one wins and his the big bad like 10
more years craziness bigger than thanos
you said it do we know what day the
what if shows are premiering i don't
know
what day is that is it a wednesday night
thursday
do you think the post credit black widow
set up the plot for hawkeye show and
that you
know it is a wednesday night yes it's
remaining on this
uh because of the spoilers but yes
answer your question yes yes i'm trying
to avoid spoilers for black widow
because this is not a black widow watch
party
uh the crosswalk today show was it me or
did kang keep mentioning gambit and also
loki as well is that a hint on the x
verse i would
really love to tell you yes but i don't
think so because loki is kind of that
character who does the gambit
and it looks like kang you know knows
loki better than anybody because
he controls he knows everything that guy
was impressive
uh i was impressed with the kids i was
really impressed with jonathan majors as
king like holy crap i
loved him so much great uh
gigathon firstly thank your videos are
awesome thank you
secondly do you think that was king or
mortis also do you think he was killed
so that he could be the true ruler of
the tva lastly
what do you think marvel's plans for
king
i do think it was mortis um i think
that part makes sense he was saving
things right
trying to keep himself away um
when he said you know when they're like
who are you afraid of he's like
me i was like yeah yes that was so cool
that was so cool that was such a baller
moment yeah
and i but but you know i'm torn between
yeah okay
this king was good but he also wanted to
rule the tva
i kind of think another kang has already
stepped in to rule the tv
and that's why i think the statue of
them of him are there
uh let's see i've addressed that one
i've addressed that one
mr lights please again with super chat
i'm calling it right now
ultron is alive and access miss
amendments and gain the multiverse
powers for income back
maybe armor warriors has supposed credit
to it maybe that would be
pretty baller like bonkers if that
happened
uh i addressed that one amalgam
cinematic universe for the win need to
see a dark claw film
there's there's so much i could do you
know just it's
blowing my mind existential markers
i hope people understand the king we get
in the future movie will not be so
comedic
the game we got presumably immortus had
been living for millennia
yeah i i that's why i was talking to you
about chris i
i don't know if he is going to be
the same personality good point
existential marxist
travis we're in the marvel cinematic
multiverse now baby and yes
we are and it's epic you can see
throughout the conversation with kang
that silvia was showing signs of getting
tricked by kang whereas loki was having
a straight face
yeah loki they mean they mean they made
that really big part at the end about
it was it was a cool scene
where's where loki said you can't trust
anybody
and i'm not trustworthy or i can't be
trusted wherever the line was i was like
dang like the loki's like
that's who they are and then they kissed
which was
i don't care i thought it was cool
uh you know was it weird i don't know
i'm not gonna dive too much into that
moral of the story like i've been saying
of loki is loving yourself
that's what we're gonna stick to i
wanted it i
i no shame in admitting that i wanted
loki and sylvia to kiss and i'm happy it
happened
and i'm happy it was king um and i'm so
happy with how jonathan may just
betrayed him in this uh
and i'm and i'm scared like it genuinely
made me frighten of
like of kang and such a good job
such a good job uh if i have missed any
super chats i'm terribly sorry
um sometimes it doesn't show me super
chats that are like
i think it's like under three dollars or
something like that
but i'm constantly scrolling through the
chat
and trying to like find them uh chicken
sticks nope
not even a little bit but thanks for
that super chat
calling it right i think i addressed the
super chats if i missed any i'm sorry
i missed mine i don't believe you
okay yeah so
i really do think that that was a
mortise you know for those
for those people asking uh that's what i
think it was um
my biggest question right now is how
does this affect
the normal movies you know how does does
eternals do they all just ignore it
you know thor love and thunder is
happening did they mention the
multiverse break
is it ignored because it's not before or
after because time's stupid right so
eternals is happening hawkeye's
happening like you said
i'm trying to like comprehend how
marvel's going to attack
ignoring the multiverse breaking in
these films i think and movie
and shows i don't know if eternals is
going to address that
because i don't think it will either i
don't think thor love love and thunder
will
but how i don't know
i think doctor strange is going to tell
us how though and i guess that is
accurate comes out first right
right so maybe at the very least he
doesn't get rid of all the timelines but
he
he wraps some tape around them and it
keeps them from branching into each
other
yeah so we might see movies appearing in
different timelines
but they don't intertwine yet until
marvel needs to undo that
and make sure to put a barrier in
between them between them
from forming but he can keep them from
crossing into each other and maybe
that's what the new tva does too
maybe because they'll be led by somebody
else right they simply
keep the timelines from interacting
jason thank you
super chat what if doctor doom wins the
second multiversal war i mean i'm hoping
that's what happens god emperor doom
right
coming to take over everything that's
what i really need to see is some doom
yeah i need some doom in my life
crosswalk today's show thanks for
another super chat when sylvia said she
was not him a loki
is that saying she was enchantress i
don't think so i think it was just her
saying that
she's not like him like literally she's
not the same variant of loki
that that he is it her character was
really a combination
of you know female loki and enchantress
alex are you guys thanks for the super
chat how do you think kang plays into
the next ant-man movie you think he
rules the quantum realm
you know they did it man's gonna take
him down yeah right
or it's a different variant that isn't
that powerful yet right maybe they start
to introduce the variance there
but you know they never told us that
they never told us if this was in the
quantum realm or not
which they didn't officially confirm it
but i don't think it was i don't think
it was either but maybe it
i do agree that in ant-man it's going to
be just one variant
but maybe there's like a quest where
it's like
hey this guy kang is the master of time
travel
i think a variant of kang is in the
quantum realm i think that city is
chronopolis i think that is a variant
of kangan there and i think they're
going to maybe escaping
maybe escaping this other king maybe
like hiding outside of space and time
because that's not inside space and time
right so maybe it was this whole time
and he'll reveal to us that that king
actually wasn't good and he was lying
you know they're this
they made our job so hard because you
could literally theorize about
anything and it could be right up to
everything
it's so hard now to make theories well
that and that is the problem is that
it's like oh my gosh anything could be
right now
no anything and it's exciting you can't
take anything off the table now and that
is exciting that's incredibly exciting
like
nothing is off the table anything goes
carlos
hanoiosa what if miss minutes gave a
location for doctor strange's fixed
timeline
like what if kang sent minutes to tell
rentslayer to find
he who can fix the timeline
it's a possibility like i just said you
can't rule anything out
but i still think kang
planned on dying
i think he wanted to i think he needed
to so he could be one he didn't say
he literally said reincarnation
reincarnate
you know which which means he's coming
back right
i mean and it's possible it's variant
trick play but
he who remains is all knowing and he
figured out how to do it you know i
wouldn't be surprised if we do see that
exact variant back
i i wouldn't either i i think we should
and i hope we do because
wow i think we should expect it yeah we
should expect it for sure marvel
cinematic
multiverse heck yeah vincent rodriguez
what king was this i love the ending but
i'm confused is more beasts get
brainwashed why was king so goofy
uh because he's old and he's and he's
kind of tired of it all and he's been
through it all and he knows how he was
mocking
explosive werewolf says can we explain
who kate bishop is because somebody in
chat is saying it's hawkeye's variant
well in the comics she's her trainee he
she's his trainee she actually takes
demand of hawkeye in the comics
and she becomes one of the members of
the young avengers i don't
think they'll make her variant um but
we'll have to see vincent regress
oh yeah uh morbius i think got his
memories erased for some reason just
like you know all the variants got their
memories erased
and i think you know somebody erased a
little bit of memories and
told him something else
uh i believe that it was a mortise uh
mark brewer
ssn what is that ssn2
to set up secret wars and battle world 2
thoughts
season two that's what that means
i think everything from here on out is
going to set up secret wars in battle
world
it's that's great that's the next
avengers in the game
and we'll probably get in like six to
seven years
jeffrey internals and shengshou were
originally slated to bring before loki
so don't think they were meant to be
affected by the events of loki
i would agree with you i would agree
with that
good thanks for pointing that out
appreciate that cordell mitchell i think
thor and eternals
are just 616. yeah i agree i think
they're just the main universe
um message retracted legendary attire
says message retracted but thanks for
that super chat um
luke lowe blew all king expectations out
of the water
yeah he was so good like
he was so great he was so good i was so
happy when i saw him i was like that's
freaking jonathan majors that's freaking
king
like the second i saw him i knew because
i was waiting for it i was like
because i was wondering is it going to
be jonathan majors or is it going to be
somebody else
right is it going to be a variant of
king but man
that was great um
it was so great jim ex-mafia
you think the x-men will appear in
future mcu does the multiverse
going to affect shank cheer turtles i
don't think it will
and yes the x-men are definitely going
to appear kevin foggy has confirmed that
they are they'll be in before fantastic
four no after fantastic
they're coming in after fantastic four
well they were still whiles away because
like
a week ago he said they're ways away
from even casting fantastic four
oh yeah lucky returns into the tva
mobius doesn't recognize him did he
return to a timeline where loki is dead
or where classic loki is hiding
um he didn't
there's the tva isn't in a timeline
and again whatever outside of it all
right and what i think is happening
is a kang came in
made the tva his and brainwashed all the
people
all the people that's what they did
originally right they got variants they
brainwashed them and thinking that they
were created by the tba right
so they've done it before they can
easily do it again
what's a good point here by someone
doesn't loki now know how to enchant
he could easily give morbius back his
memories oh there you
[Music]
why were there four time keepers statues
in the hallway before
lyft one of them was destroyed that's
strange please discuss what it means
i did notice that and either it's a
like sod it's a
it's a simple kang pulling
a trick because he knew because he knew
he see
he's seen everything right he knew that
loki and silvia would be there
because he seemed to make it pretty
clear that he was the one
that saved everything and then
right and he was the one that caused
everything
all his variants at least but he seemed
to make it pretty clear that he was the
one who saved everybody um
mr lights please classic lucky is hiding
and we'll be in the future i mean i
would love that he is clearly an
incredible illusionist so i would not be
surprised
vincent everything changed
the piazza i said it a thousand times
but
yep it did the piazza experience so toby
maguire tom hiddleston and bruce
campbell have now been confirmed for
multiverse madness
um
i wouldn't put that like a hundred
percent confirmed but i mean
i wouldn't be surprised if we saw tom i
mean it makes perfect sense for him to
show up there
david has a lot more this nick fury
cameo i would like to see that as a
perez
at this point now whenever this trailer
comes out for
for spider-man since i know that's a
topic everybody was talking about it
could
literally reveal the spider-man what do
you mean
like it could show uh
toby and andrew and it wouldn't be like
crazy it would be almost a trailer
yeah yeah so i did hear that the first
trailer teaser for no way home is not
going to show toby and andrew
he said what a the exact wording was
promotion i'll read it i'll just i won't
say who it's from
but i'll read
chris was my source guys um
and i know thanks for joining me toby
and andrew are part of the second wave
of marketing
not the first part there you go
i knew silvia would betray loki and loki
can't be happy as a registered junior i
mean she didn't i guess she did betray
him but she betrayed him
sam i know sam bestie thanks for the
super chat
uh it says message retracted can't see
it vincent thanks for another super chat
um
dang well guys we have a lot of work to
do this is going to be a heck of a
breakdown because i have so many
thoughts so i'm going to have to take a
little bit i got the super chat
oh there you go from brandon i don't
think we really expected jonathan to be
as amazing
as he was this was mind-blowing and nick
fighting had us all tunnel division like
crazy
love tom's development this series great
vibes thank you for the super chat and
honestly great point
he was amazing it was mind-blowing
and it was nail-biting that character
honestly was terrifying
and i can't wait to see him and other
variants of him in the future i'm glad
you enjoyed it
thanks for watching and for supporting
both warren and myself yup
i loved him so much uh i have a few more
but guys let's i'm going to go ahead and
say stop the super chats because we're
about to log off and i do have a stream
delay
i don't want to miss any vincent whoever
said master
10 ize one hour long breakdown no
please don't vincent where did rooney
lauren slayer go to who is miss minutes
miss menace is just a product of kang's
technology
she's kind of alive kind of not like she
explained to loki um
i don't know where she went though i
think she went to do some work for kang
uh jeff aquino tony stark nat gamora
og cap coming back via multiverse yeah i
definitely think so one point time
roger perhaps the next marvel movies a
different version of king will be taken
down
everyone will get together to take down
the final powerful king the conqueror
and the next avengers yeah no maybe not
the next
avengers but maybe yeah maybe
maybe the question is is king of thanos
or is he an ultron right we'll have to
see about that
because i don't think there's really
anyone above king i think there will be
at the end
i think like doom but love to see the
crosswalk today show did you guys notice
you kept biting an apple
as an asgardian don't do apples give
them youth and strength
uh
are you saying kang is a nice guardian
when i'ma hop off with uh and finish off
my stream and get
working but uh everybody in orange chat
thanks for uh being a part of this
awesome series and uh hopefully we get
some podcasts some other live stuff
going on
you guys aren't subscribed to chris at
cosmic culture be sure to do so he's
gonna drop the link in the chat right
now
right not right now but right right uh
right
uh i'm going
do what he said though right right right
it's not where it's loading right
thanks for the super chat there it is
pissed right now did not write his jet
ski i know but i think we will get it
eventually all right now it's in the
chat
go subscribe to cosmic culture do it do
it do it do it there it is everybody
okay thanks for chatting with me i'll
finish up my stream now
go away crash bye then uh
gamer pod heads now we wait for ant-man
and the wasp for answers yep
although i'm quite convinced it's going
to be not the main gang and ant-man on
the wasp
not like the main villain that
everybody's gonna have to take down
there was one super chat
i didn't want to miss it
oh looks like i got them all well
everyone
thanks so much for joining the watch
parties
i particularly did love loki more than
the other series that we've gotten so
far it was just so big
and so out there and done so
exceptionally well it's gonna be hard to
top this one but
i cannot express enough
how much i super appreciate all of you
um
i super appreciate the super chats the
normal chats the people who don't chat
and they just watch and they
you know we just want to be community
together i love you all this is awesome
these are so fun because of you guys and
i do get
sad like i'm sad right now that we have
such like a while before
what if starts but excuse me but i will
do some like
live stream podcast styles and in
between i'll try to do one like once a
week and they're going to be at normal
hours not
at 3 in the morning and even later for
some people it's like
5am for for some people you know so
lots of stuff to come loki was amazing
jeez kang was amazing jonathan majors
crushed it it was crushed it like really
um
jesus is it was so it was so good
so good a lot of a lot of questions we
have now but
i'm going to get working on my breakdown
it's going to take a while
but i hope you guys like it tomorrow so
i love you all
and this just marvel cinematic
multiverse as some people were saying
right marvel
marvel cinematic multiverse that's crazy
to think about
it's about to go down everybody and i'm
glad we're all in this together
and we're all going to enjoy this ride
together as well so
i will see you guys next time oh eva
thanks for the super chat glad i caught
up before i'm getting off here
and there were some parts we didn't see
but i don't think they're
that big of a deal season two is coming
a lot in between spider-man no way home
starter strange multiverse madness just
so much stuff phase four is about to get
pretty crazy for those
worried that it wasn't you know that
it's a little bit too grounded i
we're in for a treat so i'm glad to be
in this with you all uh shout out to mr
anderson for being and
for being an awesome mod it's just him
doing a lot of work
in here so thank you very much kang is
gonna
be crazy i'm so excited jonathan majors
is awesome so
all right i need to get some water and
i'm gonna start working on my breakdown
so i'll see you guys tomorrow in my
video